et ce week-end se tenait les journées
européennes des métiers d'art plus de
150 événements étaient programmés dans
les yvelines l'occasion pour le public
d'aller à la rencontre des
professionnels du territoire à saint cyr
l'école de club des huit composé de
graffeurs professionnels a exposé ses
oeuvres
tout au long de ces trois jours du 1er
au 3 avril dans un hangar désaffecté de
l'aérodrome transformé en atelier pour
l'occasion quatre artistes on travaille
en direct pour créer une exposition
évolutive permettant aux spectateurs de
voir toutes les étapes de lestang les
précisions au micro de mélanie poké
alors l'exposition elle va se fabrique
et même au fur et à mesure donc dès cet
après midi on ouvre on va commencer à
faire quelques tirages et au fur et à
mesure que les tirages seront fait donc
d'abord la gravure de la matrice ensuite
l'ancrage l'impression et ensuite le
séchage se fera directement sur les fils
qu'on a attendu la dea en gros une odeur
et papier ou une matière et c'est ce qui
fait de la gravure ce vieux métiers
quelque chose qui ce qui est encore
aujourd'hui passionnant et qui est aussi
infinie